okami bienvenue à la natif mon regard
déjanté sur le monde sportif
cette semaine on se met plus riches qui
vend ponton avec notre connaissance des
tops 5 sportif grâce aux élèves top 5 et
left et un élève fait c'est quoi un nfs
world
les élèves des linden fans des beatles
ou en français les jetons non fongible
non fongible pau-nord fongiques non
fongiques c4 comme des champignons à ses
orteils
oui qui fit non fongible ça veut dire
unique et indivisible
tout en étant complètement virtuel ça
permet d'apprendre le clin d'oeil de
patrie la poignée de main est descendue
pour la pointe où la femme de votre
pluvieux au tournoi pee wee de sorel et
les immortaliser pour l'éternité
surtout c'est votre plus vieux c'est
l'ex la fronière c'est comme ça on avait
croisé en laboratoire le marché des
cartes de hockey ahl et celui des bêtes
quand une ou deux choses qu'on ne
comprend pas pourquoi elles prennent de
la valeur mais qui ne s'aèrent d'emprunt
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment pas le temps
de rater le train d un aspect comme j'ai
raté celui des bitcoins mieux disant
gérard jodar et puis combien de bitcoins
un gérald fillion trop riche pour
radio-canada et lft ça fait cinq ans que
ça existe mais c'est juste récemment qui
embrasent le monde du sport
particulièrement la haine billets les
plus chers la plateforme un billet top
shop se transigent déjà au dessus de 100
mille dollars se donne s'est vendu 125
mille dollars américains
sept autres donc à trouver preneur pour
70 mille dollars alors que ce bloc a été
acheté 100 mille dollars
même si selon moi ça devrait être ce
fait saillant qui le numéro 10 3 avec ce
site on peut acheter un paquet de faits
saillants et dire qu'on en est le
propriétaire unique grâce à la
technologie blu chain ça te permet de
devenir propriétaire des mêmes faits
saillants qu'on retrouve déjà
gratuitement sur youtube
instagram twitter et dans la nature la
différence c'est que cette fois c'est à
toi c'est aux faits saillants de
quelques ombres tpo lebron james
tu peux essayer sera jamais lebron james
pourquoi c'est la folie parce qu'il n'y
a rien de pire pour un collectionneur de
savoir que quelqu'un a quelque part
quelque chose que tu offres personne
n'aura jamais ma plaque de joueurs du
tournoi dollar
eve de 2004 surtout pas toi en des
pigeons c'est loin ça fait comme 17,7 en
cabane à venir les élèves t c'est la
preuve que de nos jours il suffit de
dire quelque chose à un prix et il ya un
marché pour elle c'est comme quand vous
proposer d'acheter un terrain sur la
lune si vous n'êtes pas il ramasse
vous verrez jamais vos terres imaginées
maître du vent dans un bocal et le vent
parce que c'est un vin unique le marché
des élèves tvo déjà plusieurs centaines
de millions de dollars non seulement
dans le sport mais également dans la
musique et l'art visuel on vous avait
dit qu'on allait vous rendre riche c'est
maintenant sans plus attendre voici le
moment on n'a pas encore retrouvé sur
l'une ou l'autre des plateformes de nfc
et que je suis certain qu'ils peuvent
vous rendre riche le match de basket en
délivrant même et kim jong-un soft une
idée à 100 millions forcément imaginer
le plaisir de posséder le moment où
donner ce rendement donc sur kindle
lebron qui est physique on doit juste
acheté des moments passés j'ai pris une
option sur le futur en réservant le
moment où carey price soulève la coupe
stanley juste besoin du gif cherish et
se sait jamais quand mme orler claude
julien et stéphane white ont pas été
sacrifiées pourriez puis j'ai pas dit
qu'elle est la seule vers montréal avec
les nfc tout peut prendre une valeur
symbolique même un tweet
on a d'ailleurs tenté de vendre ce tweet
d'antoine dr mais ils prennent pas les
tweets à des fautes
donc je me suis inscrit sur le site pour
vendre l'un de mes 21500 tweets et j'ai
choisi le premier une réponse à marc
antoine godin brian burke se bat ce
qu'on dit doit pas valoir chat je
l'étais colisée vous pouvez trouver le
lien dans les commentaires
mais comme je suis journaliste j'ai pas
le droit de vous dire de lâcheté donc
acheté le pot je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais si on enlève les voyages
de la native qu'on joue en courbe à
gauche ça fait quel esprit ce que ça
veut vraiment dire c'est d'aimer et de
partager la vidéo
merci merci tu mens et mais les natifs
aimé dnf pris rendez vous rue achetez
pas mon truc
ah je veux juste être invité au podcast
domanova comme à la vague des jeux eu ce
bonheur là chez lui après une soirée
trop arrosée
parce que jamais son bonheur chez moi